AND D IT CHABOT.
TURNING ON THE JETS, TYLER
SEGUIN WILL OF REALLY
SPIFFY SCORING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE STARS, FIRST ONE HAS
ALLOWED.
>> Daryl: BOTH PRODUCTION ROOKIR
WITH SIX POWER PLAY
VEGAS.
THEY BASICALLY DID EVERYTHING
THEY
QUICKLY OTTAWA UP 2-0-0, PASS F
CONNOR BROWN AND OUT TO CENTER.
STARS WILL LOOK ON THE LOGO AT
THEIR BLUE LINE AND TWO GUYS GOT
BLOWN PAST, HOLTBY TO THE
IN THE FIRST.
>> Josh: HEISKANEN.
LOW SHOT.
SAVE.
GUSTAVSSON.
NICE PASS, LINDELL.
LOW SHOT. 2-0, THE CLOCK
COCO
2-0 SENS.
HERE'S JOHN HYNESS
ZUB ALMOST STICK
ONE.
HERE'S DOOR, ROBERTSON,
>> J Jyl: WELL, IT'S TKACHUK,
THE FIRST SENATOR TO BE H
BOARDS.
THREE STARS, COMES TREE,
KLINGBERG,  I MEAN, THEY NEEDED
>> Daryl: WHAT A
BACK FOR HEISKANEN.
JAMIE BENN.
FINDS THE GLASS.
BATTLE FOR IT.
HIT BY SEKERA ON THE BOARDS.
I DON'TFRONT.
TYLER ENNIS WITH IT.
ON
HIM.
12 NIGHTS AGO IN OTTAWA.AME TON.
LONG LEAD, HOME FR FACEOFF.
HEISKANEN AT THE
NETMINDER, BUT NOTHON.
GET IT ALONG THE CORNER NETMIND
GUSTAVSSON.
LOITERING